avant on utilisait le 49-3 compte on
n'avait pas de majorité
désormais on utilise le 49-3 quand on a
une majorité écrasante et qu'on veut
juste empêcher l'opposition de faire son
travail
alerte c'est le gouvernement sur le
point de dégainer le 49-3 faute d'avoir
pu convaincre le premier ministre passe
en force contre la majorité des français
en piétinant au bulldozer la
souveraineté populaire et les ans seront
comptables devant l'histoire
c'est donc fait edouard philippe vient
de se rendre à l'assemblée nationale
pour annoncer aux parlementaires le
recours à l'article 49 3 sur le projet
de loi retraites
ce n'est même pas pour des raisons de
majorité simplement car ils ne
supportent pas la démocratie
honteux je fonce à l'assemblée sur place
mes collègues tiennent la tranchée
qu'est ce que le 49-3 camp at il déjà
été utilisée éléments de réponse en
images
[Musique]
non